you know echo I'm getting a collection
actors are frequently asked you don't
mind if I do a little house when you do
what they think about other actors and
frequently the answers are interesting
sometimes the answers can be printed if
I were asked what actor I would most
like to work with it is highly possible
that I might name the gentleman who is
to pronounce the winner of the next
award mr. Sidney Poitier
those nominated for the best achievement
in film editing are Lewis are Leffler or
the cardinal Dorothy Spencer for
Cleopatra Paris Webster for The Great
Escape
Harold F press or How the West was won
Frederick Knudsen Robert see Jones and
gene Fowler Jr for it's a mad mad mad
mad world the winner is
Harold F crepes for How the West was won
the words thank you or can hardly
express my feelings at this moment but I
do want to express my gratitude to all
the young men and the woman that helped
me very much on this picture and to
stand here to accept this some such a
fine fine actor great village and great
honor thank you